what up space fam we got some crazy
happenings going on in this chapter
insane as it gets along with more Dragon
more Sabo the revolutionaries versus the
Admirals what really happened during the
revelry and the most high part a crazy
Shanks twist you won't want to miss so
make sure to stay tuned for that chill
the pirate king within and smash that
like button until you see fireworks if
you enjoy one piece updates like this
one and want to keep them coming make
this the video you joined to knock mode
by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates and
now without further Ado let's jump into
It spoilers and all so in this video we
are going to be discussing the crazy
spoilers for One Piece chapter 1083
titled the truth of that day so we're
told that the chapter starts where the
last one ended if you'll remember Sabo
was at the table with dragon and ibank
club and saying crazy but also very
hyped things he says just hearing the
information he's about to share will put
someone at risk then he said he'll tell
them all about what really happened at
the holy land of marijua so keep in mind
these are early spoilers so things will
be more clear when the full translate
Pages come out but for now we're told we
get the beginning of the flashback we
get info on the eight kingdoms that
oppose the world government because of
what happened to La Lucia and obviously
that's referring to when it got erased
Faith kingdoms refused to pay taxes to
their world government and therefore the
government decides to send a group of
people the holy nights they're called to
deal with them and it's mentioned that
there are nine holy nights definitely
can't wait to do an all nine holy nights
explained video once we know more about
this hype group and their powers pretty
crazy that we got another hype group so
far into the story so far we don't know
much but it looks like this may be a new
high powerful group like the yonko
Warlords and Admirals P.S it goes to
show how evil the world government is
that when you stop paying taxes they
immediately come after you and I like
the 7 deadly sins anime-like
continuation of blurring the lines
between Good and Evil by calling this
seemingly evil group of Fighters holy
nights so we see Sabo karasu morally and
Lindbergh versus Admirals aramaki AKA
greenbel and fujitora that in itself is
super hype and I assumed without Dragon
there Admirals would do better but it
Hypes up the Revolutionary Army that
that doesn't appear to have been the
case for starters we witness karasu
shooting crows at fujitora while Morley
manages to stab at amaki so the
Revolutionary sadly they're doing great
and then to help out the Admiral
seemingly cp0 intervenes in the battle
and it's revealed that they are also in
the possession of Vivi at this time yet
despite all this according to Sabo the
main mission was successfully
accomplished by the revolutionaries
enabling them and this is awesome to
declare war against the world government
directly by burning the world government
flag and even Kuma was freed and let's
just ignore the fact that he went back
later this is epic stuff up and I love
to see it burning the government flag at
marijuana does it get more badass than
that I don't think so and again this
makes me think that it's finally time
for Luffy the other government flag
burning guy to team up with his brother
and dad finally in a more concrete way
and it kind of makes sense that the
world government and the celestial
dragons have a new group that's been
introduced because the Admirals like we
just saw have not been looking so hot
and the world government definitely
needs something to balance this out
because they have not been looking
strong for a long time now another hype
line is that Monkey D Dragon the legend
himself is no longer playing around he
says it himself that the real war
everything he's been planning for with
the Revolutionary Army all this time has
now begun because of the actions of the
Holy nights the Revolutionary Army has
started its first move in the battle by
destroying Supply ships headed for
marijua love to see non head-to-head
fights Warfare tactics as well like this
it definitely makes sense for the
Revolutionary Army and it's definitely
adding a more real holistic feel to the
one piece story we then figure out why
Sabo was said to have killed King Cobra
of alabasta what happened was that he
was photographed next to the corpse of
King Cobra but and I'm a bit confused
with the spoilers here and maybe it will
be cleared up in the full translation
but we're then told that we also see
king cobra heading to meet the Goro say
and before he does he asks his Royal
Guards to take care of Princess Vivi I'm
guessing this happens before the corpse
part and the cp0 kidnapping vivipart
we're also told there isn't a break next
week so we can look forward to more
greatness soon but then we get more
additional information and more hype
information breaking down some of the
skim through Parts in more detail we're
told we see good action from karatsu
which should be cool to see he's
definitely got one of the most badass
Aesthetics of all the characters in one
piece fujitora is preparing for a huge
attack and the Revolutionary Captain's
faces were shocked we're told and we
don't see what happens before we jump to
so good to see that there was some
epicness on the Admiral part two because
so far it just looks like the
revolutionists have been handing it to
them cp0 we're told like me honestly are
impressed by the Revolutionary Army's
strength and they said if they were not
there the Admirals and revolutionary
captains would have destroyed everything
so it seems they were in part Trying to
minimize damage rather than just helping
to go all out against the
revolutionaries Cobra was specifically
on the floor and Dead next to his
wheelchair with Sabo next to him the
picture from the newspaper that says
Sabo killed cobra looks real because
probably it is and Morgans took the
picture after the Goro say killed Cobra
and when Sabo arrived Sabo was shocked
by the news though obviously so again
that makes more sense a fake caught
red-handed situation we are also told
that karasu's fruit is the Susu no me or
the suit fruit and it looks like it's a
logian and so it seems he just chooses
to form it into the shape of crows often
but here is the most interesting part of
the spoilers handout and this is the
part we'll look at most closely when the
full translate Pages come out one of the
Holy nights we're told in the middle
looks like Shanks and get this has the
same clothes the same sword and also the
same location of the sword now if it was
a throwaway line that he looks like
Shanks that would be different but with
all these similarities it's too much to
ignore at least from the sound of these
spoilers we know Shanks can also get an
audience what the gorosei when he wants
to and we've seen that so this seems to
confirm ideas in the vein of Shanks is a
Celestial Dragon and in this case a Holy
Night implying he is a yonko and pirate
but secretly also working for the
celestial dragons in this way of course
it could be a clone a relative or
something like that we shall see but
from the looks of it Oda is making this
a big moment and hammering down on the
similarities with purpose and I can't
wait to find out more about this
specifically the other holy nights seem
cool with one wearing a cowboy hat and
one having horns so this will definitely
be an interesting group of people I
can't wait to see all the holy nights
and the implications the reveal is gonna
have for Shanks the most hyped character
in one piece arguably now channel the
parking within and smash that like
button with no mercy if you enjoy
spoiler videos like this one and want to
see more like them in the future join
the Naka if you haven't already by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos like this one let me
know your thoughts about what you think
about all this and where do you think
we're headed what is the truth about
Shanks and why does this character look
like him and while you wait to learn
more about this hype holy night group
you won't want to miss a detailed
breakdown on the other hype yonko Group
by watching my all yako and their powers
explained video link on screen right now
and in the description Shanks may even
be a overlap between the yonko video and
my future all nine holy nights and their
powers explained video we'll see and
although I don't always end my videos
this way anymore I feel like like the
mention of a cowboy hat combined with
all of those one piece and space
theories calls for it long time fans
know where this is going until next time
see ya Space Cowboys